sólo les falta kabul este jueves los
talibanes tomaron kandahar y herat la
segunda y tercera ciudades más grandes
del país ya controlan 12 de las 34
capitales regionales afganas y los ejes
principales de las rutas hacia la
capital desde mitad de abril cuando
empezó la retirada de las tropas de eeuu
los combates por tomar el control del
territorio causaron miles de víctimas
civiles y cientos de miles de
desplazados but se cayó algo matan a los
jóvenes que tienen tatuajes se llevan
también a los adolescentes esos rumores
circulan en herat y vimos en una requisa
a talibanes matando a una mujer costado
el avance de los talibanes hace temer a
la población que una vez en el poder
impongan leyes basadas en el
fundamentalismo religioso una
preocupación compartida por faus yákov y
negociadora en los diálogos de doha
entre el gobierno afgano y talibanes
los talibanes publicaron declaraciones y
comunicados de prensa sobre el hecho que
no regresarán a lo que hacían con las
mujeres y la población pero en la
práctica en realidad vemos que en
algunas provincias la práctica es
diferente mientras el grupo insurgente
avanza en el control del territorio las
conversaciones internacionales en la
capital de qatar doha siguen bloqueadas
sobre la mesa una propuesta del gobierno
de afganistán para compartir el poder
con los talibanes según fuentes
oficiales citadas por medios hablando
ante el aumento de la violencia eeuu y
reino unido- mandaron respectivamente
tres mil y seiscientos tropas para
repatriar su personal diplomático y
dejar en mínimos su presencia en el país